- Our special teacher appreciation
hour might almost be over
but appreciation of teachers
in general will never be over.
I have one more story to share,
I hope that you'll love as much as I do.
This is what I'm liking.
(audience applauds)
So we talked all hour about how generous
and life-changing teachers can be.
But sometimes students step
up in big ways as well.
Case in point, last year Vinod Menon,
a physics professor at City
College of New York in Harlem
got an anonymous box filled with cash,
$180,000 to be precise.
After checking with the
administration box full of money,
its like amazing.
After checking with the
administration and police,
they determined it was a very real
and very legal donation to the school.
Super crazy, professor Menon
is on the line right now.
What's a professor.
How are you doing?
(crowd cheering)
- Hey Kelly, how are you?
- I am so good.
You are better.
'Cause this is crazy.
So the box apparently had
been sitting there for months,
right in the mail room.
- That's right.
The box arrived in November, 2020,
and I got the box in September, 2021.
When I went back in person teaching,
because this box had come to a room
that I normally don't go to check my mail.
And yes, I saw the box,
the box looked heavy.
I opened it.
There was a letter in there saying
that this is a donation to the department
for the wonderful education
that the person received,
and they in physics department,
and they went on to do very
well in science later in life,
and want to give back to the
college, to support students.
And then I looked on under the letter
and there was this tax
of cash staring at me.
First I thought somebody
was playing a prank on me.
I touched the cash to
make sure it was all real,
and it was.
And so I called up the
Dean, and she came down
we looked at the cash together,
and Lo and behold,
there was $180,000 sitting in there.
So we called the security,
the police got involve,
the FBI got involved to
make sure it was all clean,
and about two months later
we were informed that
it's all clean money.
So now we are going to be awarding
two students scholarships.
- That's amazing.
So do you have any idea who sent it?
- No, no clue at all.
We don't know who it is,
we've had a few people who
reached out to us saying
that they probably
know, but no clear lead,
and you know the person
wanted to keep it anonymous
and I respect that.
All I wanna say is thank you,
and we are glad we were able
to give the kind of education
that we gave to him or her,
and we are hoping that we
are continuing that tradition
here at City College.
- Thank you so much Professor Menon.
I'm liking your posts right now.
(audience claps)
And that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilate Pinmakers of Friction
to go to the Kelly Clarkson show.
Wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly,
just like you, Sir.
So they're gonna write you a cheque,
not cash, for a thousand dollars.
(crowd cheering)
And you can keep this one.